what if it's a simple question but it  raises so many more what if I had stayed  in LA how many championships could we  have won what if the Pistons had drafted  Carmelo Anthony what if Kevin Durant was  drafted number one overall in the 2007  draft  what if Steph Curry slipped one more  draft spot to the base  but what if you can make the decisions  what if you are down three Oh in the  finals could you build the team to mount  the greatest comeback of all time what  if you had the opportunity to create any  lineup for any game what have you can  choose players from any era to build the  greatest team of all time  how would you answer  welcome to my team